foreign
[Music]
there was a girl that she seemed scared
yeah that's the one I wanted oh are you
having a panic attack I think and as I'm
doing it she's crying more I'm sorry I'm
a bad person is it bad already no no
it's like okay what is the machete
tiptoeing no more no no no stalker
Patty's gonna I think she was wearing
like a Hello Kitty shirt for kids you
can't put them in something called Hello
Kitty this is not a kid man this is an
adult good
this is an adult so don't say kid I'm
glad holy grown woman bro good you get
get me oh it's all I get
Bobby Lee has been under some fire
recently as the target of numerous tick
tocks calling for his cancellation the
root of this drama all stems from a
graphic story Bobby shared multiple
times on multiple shows including Opie
and Anthony this past weekend and even
his own show tigerbelly in the story a
young Bobby Lee is looking for a hooker
in Tijuana when chaos and comedy ensue
so you know at the time I had two jokes
in my act and they would only work maybe
40 30 of the time the first joke was oh
it's not as bad it's like you know I
went on a date the other day she seemed
pretty young she looked like Natalie
Portman pause from the movie
professional right wow it's a switch
Yeah that's what that kind of joke is
dark dark the second one wait for the
second one it's way worse the other joke
that I could only get work 20 of the
time was my girlfriend's grandma died a
couple of weeks ago and last night we
were making love and she burst into
tears while we were making love and I
did what any good boyfriend would do
I power [__] her yeah 20 yeah 20
percent it's a harsh joke it's [__]
terrible and I took the Natalie Portman
joke that joke I made up this Tijuana
you know what I mean story and I look at
her face and she's crying oh so I feel
bad you know I'm a good guy right I feel
bad so I do what any good guy would do I
start power [__] her
great job creating opportunity for a
joke here by saying a shocking
provocative statement up front and then
following that up with a punchline it's
almost like Bobby did such a good job
writing this joke it matched perfectly
with the Persona he builds on stage is
this eccentric wild card that would get
naked and [__] on your car that everyone
seems to forget this story's coming from
a comedian behind a microphone who knows
he's being filmed it was a tasteless
[__] what's up joke yeah because at the
time when I said it I literally didn't
think anything of it it was just like
almost encouraged to say crazy [__] I
never thought about it when I look
listen to it now it puts a chill down my
spine it's terrible I've never done any
of that [__] because I'm not a weird
dude in that way you know I'm you know I
hate talking about myself but you know
I'm relatively just a nice kind of
die but at the end of the day the way I
get out of it is I didn't do anything
it's just it's just not real any real
comedy fan could easily wrap their minds
around why a comedian would make up an
insanely vulgar disgusting crazy story
to try to get laughs on a show but it's
important for us to remember that most
of this outrage is coming from people
like this one is one that I've been
saying for a long time comedy stand-up
comedy is full of white supremacy and
toxic masculine Behavior so as a
stand-up comedian if you don't
subscribed to that you're not gonna make
it there was however one part of this
video I found extremely disturbing and
honestly almost made me want to stop
watching Bobby Lee content for the rest
of my life wanna also tell you give you
guys an example of that and I and I hate
giving [__] away
I was never molested by a guy with Down
Syndrome it was a joke that I said on
stage right and then I just started
saying it and people would laugh every
time I would say it and it just became a
part of my origin story
look I know that there's a good portion
of what these guys say on stage or on
podcasts that's either extremely
exaggerated or just made up completely
but man never for a second did I
question whether or not Bobby Lee was
actually molested by a guy with Down
syndrome when I was nine I got molested
by a guy with Down Syndrome
it's such a curveball I know can I just
say something
I'm going to say it again and if you
smile I'm Gonna Leave okay okay
I really [__]
when I was nine years old
every day for a summer I was brutally
molested by a guy with Down Syndrome
and I'm gonna let it slide that was
pretty good I'm not smart that was
really good that's the most believable
thing I've ever heard in my entire life
and honestly it makes me really sad that
it never happened but that doesn't mean
it's not still possible this is gonna be
a hard story to tell man all right how
about this though if I say this story if
you think this is gonna ruin me will you
cut it out yes I will you promise me
yes why'd you roll your eyes bro I
didn't was looking around the room
really fast right turns out a lot more
of comedians material might be made up
than we previously thought including the
famous Tom Segura Pac-Man Jones story he
told on his Netflix special disgraceful
back in 2018. Pac-Man Jones himself was
asked about Tom's joke last week during
his appearance on the Pat McAfee show
where he claimed the story never
happened definitely not true
um I have seen the clip it's a dope ass
clip it's like Tom Segura has like kind
of like uh the locker room passes or
whatever and it was right after a
massive loss for the Bengals it's Tom
zagura and his friend is that right AJ
yeah it's Tom's girl and his friend his
friend wanted to meet Pac-Man or
something or wanted an autograph from
him and Packers walking through the
tunnel very pissed off and Tom's a
girl's friends like hey Batman a great
game can you sign like this shirt for me
and then he's like my dad love you tell
that [__] I appreciate him not
true but it was pretty fun as a big fan
of Tom Segura and the Cincinnati Bengals
I was really hoping that this one was
true I mean what's next we're gonna find
out that Burke Chrysler didn't actually
rob a train in Russia or that Billy
conforto never drove into an embankment
just kidding everything theovan says is
definitely true in the case of Bobby Lee
Tom Segura theovan and any other
successful comedian who puts out
thousands of hours of content it's
almost impossible to stay that
entertaining without stretching the
truth just like it's almost impossible
to keep up with all your favorite
comedians without subscribing to joke
world
[Music]
thank you